she is on top of the world former IBM
CEO Ginny rometti is pulling back the
curtain on her time as leader of one of
the world's biggest tech companies
rometty became the first woman to head
IBM back in 2012 and during her
eight-year tenure she transformed that
company focusing on developing Quantum
Computing and AI technology while
working to hire retain and promote women
and people of color remedy's new book
good power leading positive change in
our lives work and World details arise
from a challenging childhood to
influential Tech leader and she joins us
now um Jane thank you very much for
being here thank you challenging
upbringing is putting it mildly so the
book opens with a bang it's not giving
away too much to say you're 16 years old
and you're you're supposed to move but
your father makes the announcement that
he's leaving the family and he's leaving
your mother with no money no money for
food no money for shelter and the
family's kind of on its back how did
that influence who you became yeah well
I think many times people think it's my
father that influenced us but what
really influenced me was my mother's
reaction to all of that because I was
the one that walked in the garage and
heard him say
I don't care what happens to you I don't
care what happens to any of you for all
I care you can work on the street
and in that moment I think my mother
could have done one of two things in
which he chose to do instead was she had
no college education she had never
worked a day in her life outside the
home and but she said look this isn't
how it's going to end she's got a little
bit of Education got a little better job
a little bit of Education more a little
better job and what I took away from it
which is really what I want to share
with a lot of people my mom taught me
don't ever let someone else Define who
you are you know she wouldn't he wasn't
going to Define her as a you know single
mother on food stamps no way she was
only 34. she was only 34 with four kids
and so but the other big thing I learned
which has got a lot to do with what I do
today
it was the idea that access and aptitude
are two different things like my mom
wasn't dumb she actually was really
smart but she just didn't have access to
the type of education or those different
Pathways and that has really influenced
what I do and it influenced my whole
life after that
so you you open up about being a female
leader in a very male dominated tech
industry including a time I could not
believe this uh that you were told and I
apologize to our audience but you were
told to lose weight if you wanted to
succeed to move up the company ladder
yeah well I didn't but
you know how did that impact you though
well you moved up I moved you have to
remember you know this is now the
seventh seventies early 80s and how it
impacted me was what I'll always
remember about being a woman and
particularly woman in Tech is I was
often the only one in a room and I think
many people can identify with that
feeling and you know instead of the
negative I think of as well the positive
of it right because what it made me do
was I studied harder and harder because
I thought oh what I say is going to be
remembered right so I don't want to look
silly or stupid
and then over time what it taught me
being this only one and being an only
woman in many of these situations was
that idea about taking more risk and I
think a lot of people I I think can
identify this that I was always nervous
about it every new job oh it's nervous
nervous nervous and it was my husband
same husband I have today by the way who
um I don't know why I say that it's been
43 years will be married and uh yeah and
he said to me one day when I was so
nervous about a new job he says Jenny
why are you pausing do you think a man
would react that way and it taught me in
that moment that growth and comfort will
never co-exist yeah and it gives people
that's part of good power you know this
idea that you can create a positive
change for you you also talk about
you we us and sort of looking at a
bigger goal when you're able to you know
help yourself provide for your family
and now how does this affect everyone
else in the world
um there's a lot of speculation on the
state of our economy what are your
thoughts I know you serve on many boards
and also have you thought about running
for anything or being a part of the
political world more than you already
are with this book coming out at this
time I I think part of I wrote the book
there's a very good
point about what the world needs now it
doesn't need power it just needs good
power to make a lot of change and
there's a lot of uncertainty in the
economy I don't I don't have to you
report on it every day you had a lot of
it this morning I think the point though
is there's going to be tension there for
a long time and instead of being in
causing we they divides like Embrace
tension and you will make progress yeah
and that's what I think we need in this
economy yeah ever want to run for office
well I'm going to stay focused on
helping people get better jobs all right
Jenny rometty uh you took over 100 year
old company set it up for another 100
years in many ways thank you very much
for being here good power the book it
goes on sale tomorrow you're going to
want to pick it up we'll be right back